[Music]
so
hello
hello everyone hope you guys are doing
well
if you wouldn't mind
uh finding a seat it's actually kind of
nice seeing everybody actually talk to
each other
this is actually kind of normal
as opposed to everybody completely six
feet apart 24 7 and we can't talk to
anyone
so it's actually actually good to see
that so welcome to the table we're glad
to see you guys here
um those of you who are joining us
online we're also thankful that you were
able to join us as well
i just got a couple quick announcements
um after
the service today we were doing the save
the table uh family meeting so stick
around for that to kind of hear more
about some of the things that were going
on
for the next several months in the
future and things of that nature
so stick around for that it'll be about
6 15 for those of you who are online
going to join us for that
and then another thing i want us to do
is just save the date
so
halloween just happens to fall on a
sunday
this year so
october 31st is going to be on a sunday
so because of that we are planning on
doing some sort of trunk or treat
activity
more details about that are going to be
coming up but just want to make sure you
we put that on the back of your mind
that we're going to be doing something
i'm here for the kids and just kind of
keep that in
on the calendar
all right so we're going to start off
with prayer and get started with worship
lord thank you so much for bringing us
here today
thank you for um this community uh this
church
all the members that are here um even
the folks who are joining us online um
everyone here's such a blessing to us um
and we just want to thank you for just
the ability to be able to serve them i
pray that you open our hearts and minds
for
uh this evening for
the word that you would have for us
being able to connect with you um
and i pray that you just um
just be with us as we are connecting
with jesus in christ i pray amen
amen thank you don
don jacob jingleheimersmith
his name is don jacobs is that so
strange to anyone else i just feel like
i have to sing that song every time i
sing it every time i hear thank you
guys i'm really glad that y'all are with
us like don was saying um really quickly
before we jump into the songs this i was
talking with our team earlier
just about
the parts of worship that i feel like
sometimes i can
especially when i'm leading a set i can
approach it in such a systematic way and
i miss the whole heart behind it
and i was remembering john 4 where jesus
talking to this woman
and
these are some of his words i want to
just read them real quickly
he says believe me dear woman the time
is coming when it will no longer matter
whether you worship the father on this
mountain or in jerusalem but the time is
coming indeed it is here right now when
true worshipers will worship the father
in spirit and in truth
the father is looking for those who will
worship him in that way because god is
spirit so those who worship him must
worship in spirit and in truth
and i love one of the things i feel like
jesus is doing in this conversation is
opening up
a new paradigm for worship
and so often when we're approaching
songs especially i think if i'm sitting
out there in the audience and listening
it can be so easy to just receive it
like on almost like a cerebral level
like mentally
and disconnect from my spirit or from my
emotions or from my body
and i feel like one of the things jesus
is saying right here
is worship is about all of us it's about
our whole story and to be able to
worship him you have to do it in truth
so whatever you connect with in these
songs if there are words that resonate
with you that are true for you enter
into that space and open your spirit up
in those moments respond whether it's
maybe just closing your eyes and
meditating on those words or lifting
your hands in response or allowing your
heart to respond whatever feels most
natural for you
but our worship is one that should be a
place of truth for us and i feel like
sometimes we boil that down a little bit
too much where it's like biblical truth
instead of also what is true for me in
my life like what i've experienced this
is my moment to live into my truth
and the truth that god has met me in in
those moments where i've seen and
experienced his love his forgiveness his
resurrection in my life where he's
redeemed things so where you find
moments in this set where there are
there's truth there for you i just want
to encourage you to live into it and and
that's what we want to do up here we are
going to make mistakes and we're going
to fumble around sometimes but i hope
what we're doing
holistically as a community is living
into the moments of truth together so if
you guys want to stand with us we're
going to play through this set and let's
um take this opportunity to to be honest
with god and and live from our stories
live from our experience and live into
the truth that he has shown us
when darkness tries to roll over my
bones
when sorrow comes to steal the joy i own
when
brokenness and pain is all i know
oh i won't be shaking
oh i won't be shaken
let's sing it out
my fear doesn't stand a
[Music]
chance love my fear doesn't stand a
chance when i stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when i stand in
your love
[Music]
shame no longer has a place to hide
i'm not afraid to leave my past behind
[Music]
oh i won't be shaking
oh i won't be shaken
my fear doesn't stand a chance when i
stand in your love my fear doesn't stand
a chance when i stand in your love my
fears
[Music]
is
this power that can break off every
chain
[Music]
is
my fear doesn't stand a chance when i
stand in your love my fear doesn't stand
a chance when i stand in your love my
fear doesn't stand a chance when i stand
in your love
[Music]
is
you're the resurrection
that we've waited for
you buried the night
and came with the morning
you're the king of heaven
the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder
[Music]
we will sing a new song
cause death is dead and gone with the
winner
we will sing a new song but hallelujah
is slow like a river
we're coming back to life
reaching towards the light your love is
like springtime
you're the living water
god we thirst for you
the dry and the
[Music]
flower you're the sun the shining
you restore my soul
the deeper you call us
oh the deeper we'll go
we will sing a new song
but
[Music]
to hallelujah
reaching towards the light
we will sing a new song
is
[Music]
reaching towards the light
your love is
like springtime
[Music]
content
and like a garden i will
[Music]
i will grow
comes in the soil
hidden like a garden
and like a garden i will
[Music]
i will grow
[Applause]
[Music]
reaching toys
your love is
like springtime
[Music]
your love is
like springtime
we're going to move into our prayers of
the people and um if this is your first
time um i just want to welcome you to be
a part of it however you feel
comfortable but there's going to be a
section in the middle
um
where we have an opportunity to lift up
the things that are burdening you today
whether it's someone that you're
carrying in your heart or maybe a
situation that is heavy on your mind and
you just have the opportunity to lift up
their name or that situation and we want
to carry those burdens together and we
believe that god wants to carry those
with us and is holding those in the palm
of his hand as well um if you're online
joining us i encourage you to leave a
comment in the section and karen will be
tracking those and sharing those
with us here in this room so that we can
also engage with you guys in that way
if you see the words on the screen that
are in red please read those aloud with
us
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you
for those who travel on land see or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured and the
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for the
prisoners and the captives and for all
who remember and who care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so right now we lift
these names and situations up to you
greg
[Music]
from online daniel and karen
nancy's chemo treatments
unspoken prayer
jason
stephanie
depression and anxiety
[Music]
from online school teachers
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us and so we lift these
names and situations up to you and for
the names and moments that we've spoken
aloud and for those that we have kept in
our hearts we pray to you that they may
have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen hey
peace
bring it all to peace
the storm surrounding me
let it break
at your name
still
call the sea to steal
the raging meat is still
everywhere
[Music]
at your name
jesus jesus
[Music]
will make the darkness tremble
jesus jesus
you silence fear
you make the darkness tremble
jesus jesus
[Music]
breathe call these bones to live
call these lungs to sing
once again
i will
praise
jesus jesus
you make the darkness tremble jesus
jesus
[Music]
your silence fear
jesus jesus
you make the darkness tremble
[Music]
oh jesus jesus
oh
we cry out to you
make the darkness
[Music]
your name
is light that the shadows can't deny
cannot be overcome
[Music]
your name is alive
forever lifted high
your
name cannot be overcome
sing that out your name
is a light
that the shadows can't deny
your
name cannot be overcome
yeah
your name is
[Music]
be overcome
this is not jesus
jesus jesus
you make the darkness triple jesus jesus
your silence fear
jesus jesus
you make the darkness tremble jesus
jesus
[Music]
your name
is a light
that the shadows can't deny
your name
cannot be
your name is alive
forever lifted high
your name
cannot be overcome
let's just lift our voices up your name
is a lie
that the shadows can't deny
your name
cannot be overcome
your name is light
forever lifted high
your name
cannot be overcome
[Music]
yes god
would you bring the light of christ into
our darkness
just as you have done so many times
before god just as you did when you came
to this earth
and you entered into our brokenness and
you took on our
flesh
and you became the light of our world
would today be another day that we see
you bringing your light
god and shining out in the darkest
places of our world
would you bring your redemption
would you bring your forgiveness
and your beauty and your creativity
would you bring your power
the things that can conquer
racism the things that can conquer
hatred the things that can conquer
sickness and viruses and death would you
bring that light tonight into our lives
and would we carry it out into this
world god would we carry your light
inside of us would we feel it changing
us from the inside out god
we need
light
we need you
we need the hope that you bring
we're lost without it god
we're lost and broken and sick without
it
[Music]
thank you for this time together thank
you for community that can carry one
another's burdens
that can shoulder the pain and the hurt
that we deal with god and they can
celebrate with us and surround us in our
moments of joy in our moments of victory
god
would we come together would we be a
force of unity and peace and life and
light just as we've spoken god tonight
open our ears to hear your voice speak
to us through the people who are going
to share their stories tonight god
give them a peace and a calm
we just look forward to hearing them and
we celebrate the victories and the
beauty that they've experienced in you
it's in your name i pray amen
to the people around you sorry
well good evening good evening everyone
uh grace and peace it's really great to
be with you my name is brett i'm the
founding pastor here and
um yeah just wonderful wonderful to be
together and to center on christ and
and just i don't know just be together
it's good yeah the lord's faithful in
the midst of all of the trials and there
are many i'm pretty in the loop on many
of your lives and i know there's a lot
of trials out there um so yeah god is
faithful and thank you mindy in
the whole worship team for leading us so
beautifully in that um
so we are um
coming into what we technically you kind
of
had our last message in the
deconstruction series
last week but uh what we're going to do
like mindy mentioned is hear from some
folks tonight who are going to be
sharing their stories kind of their own
stories of
deconstruction and for those who weren't
here for the series
the the idea of deconstruction is
basically um at least what it's come to
mean in kind of church circles um not in
its post-modern philosophical academic
sense but in you know church
here it's come to mean kind of a season
of doubt
a season of wrestling a season of
questioning um received inherited
theological beliefs um that we just
picked up from culture often from church
culture
and
eventually uh a number of of us kind of
reached a point where some of those
things um it wasn't not not that they
weren't working in like a um kind of
selfish sense like these aren't making
me feel good you know because sometimes
the truth can hurt right so it's not
about just feeling good
but um it was bearing bad fruit bad
results in our lives
um it was full of shame it was full of
kind of angry unchrist-like images of
god
there were just some some challenges and
problems so the kind of point of this
series was to to work through some of
those topics so we um went through all
sorts of things from divine violence to
um
hell understood as like eternal
conscious torment um the problem of
suffering you know and so on and so
forth so um we even did a little
deconstructing of kind of north dallas
religion apart from christianity and
consumerism and
you know there's all sorts of beliefs
and ideologies that don't bear good
fruit in our lives um and at times it's
kind of bad um you know maybe christian
theology but um
yeah that's kind of our goal is to find
to see the beauty and to start to get us
on a path towards um reconstruction so
um so that's kind of been been the
series so like i mentioned we're gonna
have some some folks share their stories
tonight and
the reason i really like for us to do
this is really twofold and don't worry
this will not be a long sermon we'll get
to their stories um but two two reasons
first um is i i think it's just kind of
helpful in our culture to slow down and
reflect you know we're very much an
on-the-go culture always moving always
kind of on to the next thing so it's
like okay great wrapped up the
deconstruction series last week let's
keep moving forward next thing and i
think it's helpful at times to kind of
pause
and reflect on what we um what we've
heard
and um
and in a culture that can be you know
can just so lack that you know can lack
quiet can lack time to reflect you know
reflect think about my life oh gosh i
don't know when am i gonna do that i'm
too busy you know so i think it's
helpful i mean man if there's anywhere
we should be able to do that it's church
i like to take some space and be like oh
that's right
god
and and just re-center and um and kind
of reflect on on that so my hope is that
as people share their stories
you kind of are able to get insight and
um
uh kind of wisdom for your own
story in your own life um that it's kind
of moments of like revelation you know
an insight of like oh my gosh that i
relate to that you know um so that's
that's the first reason it's kind of
just helpful to slow down and reflect
and then second
is that it's just flat out encouraging
to remember and realize that i'm not
alone
you know
especially when we're wrestling with
doubts and
you know struggles and suffering
it's so powerful to hear someone else's
story
and realize oh my gosh
i'm not a crazy person you know people
are like wrestling with similar things
um
and uh and that can be yeah it can be so
helpful so first thessalonians 5
verse 11 says therefore encourage one
another and build each other up just as
in fact you are doing
and so um that's kind of what i hope
tonight is just i hope it's encouraging
i hope it's thought provoking
and life-giving for for all of you
so uh with that in mind i want to invite
up um nancy purdy
we all give nancy a hand
here yeah thanks jesse
all right
so nancy thank you for being here i know
you know being on the stage being up
front is like not your necessarily your
jam um
but i'm i'm really grateful that you're
um willing to kind of step out and and
do this because if y'all don't know
nancy she's an amazing person an amazing
person like so much depth and sorry i'm
building you up and now you're like oh
gosh now there's pressure
um but
but you are you're awesome so um i
wanted to to kind of start by um having
you just share a little bit of like your
own
kind of church upbringing and you know
some of your own like received inherited
theology and you know where was your
starting point before
you got into that kind of whole you know
deconstruction time so i i made notes
because i don't think really fast on my
feet so
i'm sorry i'm sorry and you can tell i'm
used to doing this um
so i made notes so if you see me looking
down it's because i don't think really
fast
on my feet so
my
upbringing was
i was born into the southern baptist
church my dad was a pastor when i was
born
so it was sort of it sort of became a
stew
of southern baptist
the base
institute in basic youth conflict bill
gothard i don't know if anybody
was damaged by that also
um and positive thinking like
dale carnegie
so that kind of
that was all a stew is what i grew up in
um so there was lots of fire and
brimstone
lots of rules
lots of shame
um but also have a positive thoughts to
be financially successful
and most important
do not do anything to embarrass your
family
small town
that you know don't don't do anything
that could bring shame to your family um
unforgiveness was okay
holding grudges were okay
not saying you're sorry was okay
um
gossiping was okay
but you know make sure you're
reading your bible make sure you're
going to sunday school do not miss any
school that's just a major sin
um you know so you can check off all the
things when you turn in your envelope
every sunday morning
so
god's love
or jesus teachings were not really a
thing
it was mainly
become a christian so you don't go to
hell
and then beyond that it was just follow
all the social rules
so um
so one of the
messed up theologies was this idea of a
diamond
um god had a plan for you god had you
know his will
what he wanted
and every time you sinned
or made the wrong decision god had to
whack off
part of that diamond so you just became
smaller and smaller
so everything was weighed
and everything was
you just whacked and whacked and whacked
and whacked
so
to me
that really goes against the whole idea
of
a vine that's growing and pruning it so
that it can grow
and be stronger and healthier to me the
the diamond idea of getting smaller and
smaller and smaller
is totally
not
of god
so
so that's sort of what
i grew up in
yeah so it's a pretty
rigid
um maybe just putting it mild yeah rigid
rigid and also weird where like
don't go into town wearing shorts
because that's a sin but go
into any sporting event wearing the
shortest of shorts
and that's okay because that's your
uniform
yeah
yeah which is where often the kind of
rules end up being a little bit
nonsensical when you try to rule
everything and yeah yeah yeah so um
so eventually i'm guessing there was
some
i mean it probably wasn't one like
moment although maybe there was like a
moment but was there kind of a moment or
a series of moments or like what was the
transition
for you or the process to start kind of
down that kind of questioning
and changing your theology and that
really probably led you into you know a
season of kind of deconstruction what
was that all like i think there was
always things in the back of my head
like the shorts issue and the diamond
issue and you know just uh why is this
okay here but this is not okay
here why is it okay to sit you know have
these big gossip sessions but
it's not okay to
dance or
drink but it's okay to smoke
because you're southern baptists
and you have to support the tobacco
industry
um
so those kind of things were always but
as i was telling her i'm the nine and
i'm meaning graham nine so i am a fly
under the radar
you know
and also
it was not safe to ask questions
you were shut down really fast with
god says it's a sin
and that's the end of the discussion
you asked the question boom
so i had things percolating
so when i was
in my early 30s i had my kids
i
came to the realization that i had just
been
that my faith was not my own
that
anything that was in there
was just inherited
and i did not want that for my children
and so that started me
thinking
and um and i
i would say i coasted for a long time i
was like maybe in the services
because there's still southern baptists
not in not all churches
just the ones i found myself in um
so uh just
i was just there i was on autopilot i
was doing it because i was supposed to
it was a social thing
but it had no deep it had no depth that
had no meaning i was in the bible
studies i was teaching sunday school i
was doing all the things but it was
strictly autopilot
was what about like
for you
i mean you're kind of describing
autopilot was there like some sort of
deeper connection with god or even was
that sort of like man that really was it
was just not there was just this kind of
yeah one thing that i would say is that
i always said in the back of my mind
that nothing could separate from me from
his love
so i always had that in my the back of
my mind you know romans
8 38 and 39
um and i think that was
um
if i hadn't had that
i don't know
i don't know where i would have been to
that yeah that was almost like something
to move towards in a way or something
yeah something that just kept me buoyed
i think
yeah
so so you mentioned kind of
30s
kids you're thinking like i don't want
to just replicate what i you know where
i was what did um
what did that look like as you kind of
pressed into you know asking the
question like you said it wasn't really
safe ask questions but eventually you
kind of felt the need to do that
and then so what was that kind of
season like i think 9 11 really
shook me up
as far as um
what
it sort of it really opened my eyes to
um
the ugliness of the relationship between
american christianity
and
what my heart
felt like
it should be
that i was not seeing love i was
definitely not hearing love
from the pulpit
and i think that
sort of set me
to looking or being aware that there
were other voices out there and once
there was that
that awareness
i started seeing
i started seeing people who were feeling
the same way that i was
yeah started to realize you're not alone
right
who just had a curiosity who are some of
those voices um red letter christians
that organization shane claiborne um you
know anybody that was speaking love
against the hate
um
was
making me you know perk up and listen
yeah
um
so all right so you kind of make this
transition you start engaging claiborne
and other red letter christians and i
pretty much checked out of
my
church family like i was there to do my
things but as far as that like i was not
in the
yeah i was
there were for long periods of time that
i would be i would not even step into
the sanctuary
i was like behind the scenes doing my
stuff you know
but um
very much checked out of the
um
of that and was just you know
searching and listening for people
yeah
so did you find that your kind of
season of deconstruction question asking
and then your reconstruction kind of
just blended it like with it
i think so i think so um there was also
um and and it's like at all
it's like there were i don't see like
seeds planted or you know things that
were always there
that um
that you know i can look at back and go
oh
um but um
i was really um
questioning hell
also at the same time and i
i think it was
that started when princess i'm really
showing my age when princess diana died
a friend of mine
housekeeper was very very upset was just
distraught because she was so worried
about princess diana if she was going to
heaven or hell
and um this person said to her
oh she's in hell you're just going to
have to accept that and go on
pretty confident yeah and i was like
and so that started this chain of
questioning in the back of my head of
and so and that when i mean like
because i'm a nine
i did not feel safe asking questions out
loud
so there was a lot of turmoil in the
inside
and questions that i just
kept asking myself and sort of looked
here and there
and so
it was nothing that happened overnight
there was never any overnight it was
long periods of time of searching and
listening and
and then um when um
rob bell came out on his book and made
the world explode love love wins um yeah
that one or a different one no that one
yeah so um a book about about hell for
those who are yeah and i had already
been a fan of his
you know so i was already a little
strange in my world
um
so uh yeah when that
that was like
oh
it was just like
yes i can totally relate to this and
then i think
micah introduced me to brian zahn
because you introduced you know so um so
yeah just little little things happening
and then with the lgbt
you know q
um family and
um i'm old enough
that kids started coming out
that i had seen things when they were
small
that when they came i was like oh
okay and
and then i saw families reject and
families kick out and families shut
doors and like that is not
love
so that made me start searching
and researching and finding
and you were one of the people that
helped with that but
some and you know rachel held evans
helped in that matthew fines just
different people
for that part but it was yeah there was
long processes i mean
you know sometimes 30 years
of things that
i tucked away
but then came back i'm like oh okay
it's like prepare it it was like my
heart was being prepared
for these changes that were going to
come out
globally you know
yeah
yeah how so like i said it's kind of
like a blending of your deconstruction
it was just sort of all along you have
the question and then you
deconstruct the idea and then you start
moving into like okay what do i think
now but was there anything um
like in that
kind of i don't know was there anything
else in the time of reconstruction you
can ask that like as you
i'm guessing there's been some sense of
maybe a little more subtleness not that
you're ever like oh i've arrived and now
i have no more questions but in the
sense of like not quite in that same
inner turmoil you know in in terms of
kind of settling a little bit more have
you found that i want to put words in
your mouth but in terms of a season of
kind of reconstruction like okay i think
this is where i am now with you know god
and christ and you know all that i think
i'm old enough
i'm old enough to
know
and i've learned that i have to hold
everything with open hands
and so i don't
the the thing that i really truly cling
to is that
nothing can separate me
from the love of god
so i think that's
yeah i mean that's where i am it's like
and also another thing is
of i might have it wrong here
but that that's okay
it's okay
as long as i'm not
hurting people
oh so yeah or bringing harm to them
so yeah
is there um you've kind of already given
a few
insights there but is there anything
else you would share with someone here
who's
in their own kind of season you know
deconstruction records they're just
maybe a little bit upside down and like
i don't know you know what's going on
what would you say i would say listen to
the stirring of their heart
it's there for a reason
ask questions
find safe people to ask questions with
find a spiritual director
that has helped me
greatly um and you maybe describe that
person a spiritual director just sort of
helps you um
unpack things helps you find um and they
don't even have to be they're not
necessarily christian
they're just helping you find spiritual
practices
that help you
advance
you know in your faith
um
and they're willing to uh
you know work with you to help you know
like i i
i stink at some prayer practices i'm
just
you know
so you know they just help you
find things that work with you well that
work for you to connect you with god in
a way to
um
so
so spiritual director find the spiritual
director um if you can
find safe people
that's important and i feel like we have
that here
and
also
you know just never forget that there's
nothing that can separate you from the
love of god
nancy thank you
you're awesome you give her a hand
all right
next i want to invite up
raymond lester
the great
y'all give him a hand
raymond it's been a joy getting to know
raymond the last um it's been a while
you were attending online for a long
time and then you kind of moved a little
bit closer and yeah getting to know you
so i encourage you if you haven't got to
know raymond um get to know him he's
just
how would i describe raymond like he's
so personable
easy to get to know such kindness so
we're so glad to have you a part of our
community
um
i don't know if you want to take your
mask down it's kind of hanging there you
go yeah um
so maybe um kind of tell us um you know
how how did you start out you know what
was your church upbringing what was your
received inherited theology
yeah where was your beginning point
that eventually led you to you know ask
some questions and have to deconstruct
that okay
well i my earliest memories are in
church
i would sit at the end of a piano
my aunt was a terrible piano player and
some of my earliest memories are
plunking on the piano while she played
and i improved it for the service
but so i i
grew up in church
my
parents divorced when i was really young
but i was still in church throughout
that in that entire time so i had early
childhood trauma
but i had this sense of knowing that i
was loved and that i was cared for by
god so that was something that
really
went beyond any human explanation
so i've always found myself finding a
safe place
and so
[Music]
then of course as i grew up
things in my life happened to me that
caused me to
it i found it difficult to reconcile
what i knew to be true
that i was loved
by god
because what you know i grew up then i i
grew up in a church where the motto was
it makes a difference
what you believe
so which interpreted means
we believe the right way and if you
don't believe the way we do then you're
out of line
and so
i i
heard that as an early child and then of
course you know this is very dualistic
thinking that if you do this
then god will meet you and if you don't
then you perish and so there was this
whole
this whole pressure to this decision
point it's all about
you know the sermon
and the invitation
and that moment where your life changes
and so that's there's all this pressure
there
so i grew up in that environment you
know i loved god i felt loved by god i
loved music i felt a connection
i i felt the holy spirit and and
recognized that but there was this
turmoil because you're supposed to do
things this way
and so i remember you know
having trouble reconciling that
all these people are going to go to hell
and it's your fault because you didn't
take them the news
and so i struggled with that and i had a
real turmoil because i already felt like
that i was connected to god
but i needed to
make that decision i needed to pray that
prayer
and so
you know that was the first conflict
that that happened in my life as a as a
child
but then of course i
went through the motions i walked the
aisle did all the things they were real
to me but there wasn't just a moment i
just had this knowing
that you know god wasn't
restricted to getting his message to me
through somebody else
and so
i you know was always involved in church
involved in youth groups but i was
always a questioner
i always questioned when things didn't
make sense
and so
i as a teenager my friends and i we
would just hop churches if i had a
friend that went to a different church i
would go there to listen to how they
knew this is the way it's supposed to be
and then i would you know i go to the
church of christ people and you know
they really know how it is they're
confident yeah they are
and then the pentecostals you know they
had they had their way and you know
you're so confident yes and so i just i
was always questioning
and so um
but you know i still went through the
motions and you know after high school
i went to bible college i was involved
in church ministry but i still had all
kinds of questions and
i um
you know did all the right things you
know i i knew at an early age that
something was a little bit different
from me as far as sexuality was
concerned
and so but you know you don't talk about
that you it's hush hush those are
secrets and there was lots of secrets in
my family
but so i got married because that's what
you do because you you know if you get
married it'll all go away
and so you know i worked really hard i
mean i had friends of mine who struggled
in the same way and i was their role
model because i was doing it the right
way
little did they know that i the struggle
was still real
so you know i was very involved in in in
the word spent you know prayer was
really important to me real disciplined
prayer life lots of intercession
lots of scripture
so i that was all a part of who who i
was
but i really struggled with reconciling
that part of me
and so you know i'd deal with guilt and
shame it was just a whole shame cycle
but i could find freedom
from
things like lust that was a real thing
and i that went away so i knew that god
could answer prayers
but it's funny how he took the lust away
but he didn't take away
my attraction
you know and so
that caused me to you know still
continue
to to wonder
and so i just
again just sort of went through the
motions but continue to always challenge
and ask questions because
you know
when you're in a church people they have
these beliefs and they they know
everything they know when people die
they know exactly what happens they know
where they go they know what it's like
they don't either
and so that was always a struggle for me
these people talking about when people
die this is what happens so then you
don't really know what happens to them i
understand scripture says that to be
absent from the body is to be present
with the lord and that rings
a bell and rings true to me but you know
them going and meeting up with a whole
bunch of people and doing all who knows
i don't know
and so
you know i've always questioned and
challenged whether i did it overtly or
internally i always challenged um those
things that just didn't seem to make
good sense yeah just wasn't settling
right yeah
and and honestly the one of the things
that you've uh spoken that's really rung
true and it's sort of the
the way that i've tried to lead my life
is that
deconstruction is the smashing
of idols that separate us from the god
who is love and so
to me that makes it real easy
because if you if you
you know take a look at some of these
ideas and these thoughts
and if you measure it against love it
really gives it a whole new meaning
yeah
was um
was there kind of uh well i think you
mentioned earlier there wasn't
necessarily a key moment but was
what was it like as you
kind of entered into that season of like
well let me just ask it this way like
was there a time where you really kicked
off your own like those questions really
started to get very real and have some
major consequences in your life and then
what was that season like okay
well i
um
because i lived with such secrets so
many secrets and a lot of shame
which was
not fun
and overwhelming and difficult and
painful you know i had one child and i
had another child and so i was trying to
do all those all those things
but i
started to
just listen
listen to different ideas
and i mean a couple of years ago
i connected i started to begin to accept
who who i was and realize you know what
pic i found this group of people who are
part of reparative therapy and they were
you know praying the gay away
and many of them were christian
and so i started connecting with them
and it's through seeing the holes in
that philosophy
that really helped me
find a place of self-acceptance
and so they would talk about you know
same-sex sex attraction and unwanted
same-sex attraction and i thought
mine's not unwanted it just is
green is my favorite color
and boys are my preference
and it's not something that you just
decide it's just it is
and so i begin to accept that and it's
funny that i was rubbing shoulders with
a group of
reparative therapy people that i
realized that
i'm okay with who i am and whenever i
begin to accept that all the shame began
to go away
i felt i didn't feel
any i didn't feel the compulsions i
didn't feel the shame i didn't i it just
i began to i began to accept myself and
more importantly begin to accept the
love that god so freely gave to me
wow is
so it sounds like that kind of led into
this season of what the language we've
been using as reconstruction or this
kind of settledness what was that okay
yeah what was that experience like so i
found this group this just dinner group
that's where i met don over two years
ago
and this is a group of people that you
know
many are of faith some are not
but it was a group of
people who were either
gay or bisexual or somewhere fluid in in
that mix and they
found comfort in
and acceptance
and affirmation
um
from one another
and so that just really it helped me
sort of own who i am
and find some freedom and through that
you know i started listening to podcasts
you know
like the liturgist podcast and i'd
already i was already familiar with rob
bell and really and you know i was
listening to him before he really you
know
went to the dark side
and so you know i just began to to
listen and spend time with and
communicate with people and fellowship
with people and hang out with people and
i
i i reached a point in my life when i
was no longer
hiding anymore so if the issue of being
gay came up you know if someone asked me
i'm not going to lie to him but i didn't
you know i didn't start putting glitter
on and waving a rainbow flag like don
but
but i found real acceptance in that and
you know eventually came out to my
children you know i have an older
daughter who's a lesbian and so you know
i sort of made amends to her and let her
know that she was accepted and loved and
so i've just you know been sort of
shaken off those
chains that those idols
had
had on me
wow
what um
for someone
who's maybe going through something
similar to you what would you what would
you say to them how would you encourage
them or any insights for them
question
questions are good you know scripture
says to seek first seeking is about
inquiring it's about asking questions
and it's about listening
but you know
i tell
anyone
never stop asking questions
because if you ask questions
you'll get answers if you seek
you will find if you knock the doors
will open
and so that's my biggest encouragement
is
and again if you take
these false beliefs these things that
you've been taught and you know plus i
have a lot of friends who are christian
who are
you know who may be gay but those
those roots of those false beliefs as a
child are so strong
and you know it's it's it's hard to find
it's hard to understand that you'll have
someone
that is gay but they're homophobic
because those
roots go down really deep and we're just
raised to believe
that this is the way it is and we have a
hard time
you know getting away from that so my
biggest thing is always follow the way
of love
because that's the only thing that
really doesn't fail
and never stop asking questions
wow thank you can you give him a hand
[Applause]
you raymond all right kasia
come on up y'all give cash a hand
my good friend kasha watts
um kesha has
been um
kind of a part of our community for a
while even going back to our previous
church plant um neoplucus she was a part
of that her and her husband jessie
and um
kesha now serves as our
administrative assistant she also does
like online social media stuff and she's
yeah we're grateful for cash i'm very
grateful for gasha
so um yeah it's wonderful to have you
here um so tell us a little bit of your
starting place you know where'd you
start church-wise what and what was it
what were some of the beliefs or ideas
that have eventually led you to needing
to you know do some deconstruction
um i think what's different from me is i
can't remember like a specific bad
church experience as a child um my like
bad faith experiences came from my
family
um
we grew up in
not a southern baptist but you know like
in the midwest christian churches are
also kind of southern baptists
so um i think a lot of their thinking
was just fear-based and it was just
really interesting how
i had my mom is gay
and so i wasn't allowed to see her
but my dad has been divorced four times
and arrested for domestic violence and
that was okay
so that was like where my questioning
and like
the
it didn't make sense to me christianity
really so
i lived with my grandmother most of my
life though and she was it was just her
faith was so beautiful but she just had
a lot of fear
and when i was 14 i went to the quaker
church which i know sounds like
mennonite it's not quakers are the best
and
um but there was a lot of differences so
a lot of these
performative sacraments like communion
and baptism
like worship that we do here is not part
of the quaker church it's because they
see it as performative
and so it's a lot of like the holy
spirit is the inner light so it's a lot
of inner work but to my family those
were what got you to heaven
those performative acts so
i just started changing as a person
and being a part of the quaker church of
non-violence and stuff they were just an
acceptance and inclusion
it really scared them for my soul
and
then we got into ministry really young
and that's where i saw a really ugly
side of church of
we kind of went back to that midwest
southern southern baptist type church
and women did not have a voice
and if you had a voice you were just
like a jezebel
and so um that rebellious spirit was
india or something yeah
and so
you know
there's just i have a lot of terrible
stories but just like accidentally
walking in on my husband on a meeting
and the whole elders have to have a
meeting with my husband about how i need
to be calmed down as a woman
and so
um
because was it the
confidence of which you burst in the
meeting i just walked in i didn't even
know they were meeting okay
but it was a big no-no
women weren't allowed where elders were
meeting
so
i so that really
just like totally cut me down
and made me angry
yeah so it's almost like
where you started off you you're
received your inherited theology you
feel like just so much of it was so good
and helpful yes but then you entered
into in your adult years kind of church
spaces where
that was not acceptable or ugly
it was different theology and so that
became
you know kind of a struggle can you talk
about a little bit more some of those
years and eventually where that
kind of led you you know
um
what year specifically like in ministry
or i'm thinking of your
kind of your own season where you
weren't even sure about yeah all the
whole thing yeah so um i've always been
a questioner
and um
like jesse always says that he can
remember from the moment he met me like
me being like which was jesus really the
son of god like
i mean that's pretty extreme like
so
i always kind of question those things
but then
i never felt really this safe space and
i had a lot of fear like
if i question
and i'm wrong what does that do to being
married to a pastor what does that do to
my soul
and stuff like that so
we were at a service where we were
listening to a buddhist
who had been researching christianity
and he said the thing about christians
is they're so
scared to question things but if it's
the truth won't it be on the truth on
the other side of questioning
and i was just like oh no
like
so
that really opened it up and then there
was this song by sean watkins the god
you serve
and it talks about um that was my moment
in the car i had to pull over and it was
just like oh my god i don't believe
anymore
it just talked about
well if the god you serve is so great
why do you have to do all these things
to get to heaven
and so
that
really brought me to my questioning and
yeah and just for context how long ago
was this like what timeline 2018 yeah
yeah yeah so pretty recent yes but um
so you kind of reached that point what
was it what was the process i don't know
if it was a moment but what was the
process to kind of
bring you out of that and yeah so um
i there's been a lot of moments but
really
getting to know myself and
accepting who i am as a person and
i'm very intellectual so i want to know
the intellect of things and
i have always been a person that's
questioned like i've never got downloads
from god
or anything like that and realizing that
the way i experienced
jesus was also human and so the way i
experienced god's presence is through
my own humanness so through human
interaction
uh
having a good day with my family
being out in nature that's how i
experience the presence of god so it was
just like reframing who is
god and how do i experience him
and
claiming my voice as a woman and that
it's okay
to have a voice
making amends with my mom
[Music]
and i'm a child of a queer
person
it's just really starting to have that
acceptance of myself
and
jesse always learned in therapy sorry to
call you out that you're going to
therapy but
he says that it's an honor he always
says this it's an honor to be in a
relationship with you
in that
everybody should feel that way it is an
honor for people to be in relationship
with you
i think with god we always think we have
to do performative acts to be in
relationship with him but it is also an
honor for god to be in relationship with
us
and what that means is with you who you
are
not your performative acts but actually
with you so it's a very two-sided
relationship not just
i have to do things to please him
he also loves being in relationship with
me too and who i really am
wow what um
any
any other input for people who are in
their own
season you know i mean you said well you
said it was beautiful but maybe if you
have anything else
um yeah that would encourage or
any wisdom for them um
therapy
getting to really accepting and getting
to get those strongholds away and
accepting who you are and like i said
it's an honor to be alive and to be a
part of this human experience and it's
an honor to be in relationship with you
god feels that way too he wants to walk
with you through your questions and your
experience so
yeah that's what i would say
yeah thank you yeah thank you thank you
i'll give her a hand
[Applause]
man we have wonderful people here don't
we isn't it great to get some insight
and man yeah i i love it so let me pray
and then we'll transition lord thank you
thank you for tonight thank you for the
chance to um
hear
um
just your heart for people
god that you love us right where we're
at
that we're accepted
regardless of how well we perform
that you're more than just rules
but you're calling us to um lives of
love and relationship and connection and
uh hope and
um even self-acceptance of just being
okay with who we are and how you've made
us
so god we thank you for that and
and we just say yes to it
we receive it
yeah we love you lord
help us in our journey to
deconstruct and reconstruct well
it's in the powerful name of jesus that
i pray
amen
[Music]
thank you guys so much for sharing your
stories that was so beautiful
so
if you guys want to stand with us we're
going to wrap up with this last song
and i hope that we're able to kind of
hear the lyrics through some of those
stories through the filters of those
stories of
hearing that god loves you just as you
are hearing that your questions are
welcome
and that he he wants to be in a
relationship with us
[Music]
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
i believe that you are my fortress
oh you are my portion
[Music]
you are my hiding place
oh i believe you are
the way
[Music]
the truth
the life
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
i believe through every blessing
through every promise
through every breath i take
[Music]
you are the one i love
i believe you are
the way
the truth
[Music]
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
i believe you are
[Music]
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you meet me here today
with mercies that are new
all my fears and doubts
they can all come too
because they can't stay long
when i'm here with you
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you meet me here today
the mercies that are new
all my fears and doubts
they can all come too
[Music]
the truth
i believe you are
the way
the
truth oh i believe you are
i believe you are
[Music]
thank you guys for worshiping with us
oh
um thank you all for uh joining us this
evening um
just a couple of reminders we are gonna
have our state table meeting um after
this service so give us a couple minutes
to kind of change some things out
so we'll be able to do that um also
don't forget about the trunk or treat
that we're gonna be doing here in the
next month or so on a halloween night um
if you're a visitor with us thank you
for coming um we'd love to hear from uh
get us
some basic information from you there's
some is regards you can
sign for us on the back table in the
hallway love to hear from you
also if you'd like to give there's a way
to do that with the envelope and there's
a box also out
in the front as well you can also do
that online
um and there's directions also on the
screen on how to do that
if you're in need of prayer i'll be here
up front i would love to be able to pray
with you through
whatever it is that's going on in your
life
especially with the topic that we've
been discussing over the last several
weeks i know that this kind might bring
up a lot of different things and we are
here to support you
so with that being said i'm going to
just let you go just go in god's love
god's grace and god's peace throughout
the rest of the week bye
[Music]
sitting down